[Music]
good afternoon and thanks for joining us
i'm dr sarah blosser and along with
today's moderator dr priyanka cupretti i
work for roche diagnostics in the area
of medical and scientific affairs
one of the purposes of our team is to
provide education on a broad variety of
topics in a non-commercial way
the part partnered with lab roots for a
number of webinars in 2022 when we were
thinking about a respiratory based
webinar we of course thought of coded
but what should we talk about that
hadn't already been covered
very quickly we focused on public health
the public health laboratory
specifically and their journey as an
area that really hasn't been given a
very big voice to date
and so the concept for this webinar was
born
today you'll hear from three speakers
all presenting from three different
public health laboratories perspectives
we hope you enjoy these tales from the
lab as we walk through the journey that
the pandemic created for us we hope you
laugh with us cry with us mourn with us
and celebrate with us
but most of all we hope you learn about
the challenges and triumphs faced by our
truly amazing public health laboratories
and with that i'll turn it over today's
to today's moderator
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the covet 19 public health
experience
my name is priyanka and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is presented
by lab roots and brought to you by roche
diagnostics
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them type the
questions in the ask the question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
i would now like to welcome our speakers
for today
our first speaker will be dr
elanastrico dr striekel is currently an
assistant professor at the university of
wisconsin-madison
and the associate director for the
communicable disease division at the
wisconsin state laboratory of hygiene
our public health lab was the first in
the state to test for sars cool v2 and
has undergone more than 30 validations
to keep it running at this point
dr striegel supports the molecular
testing not only in her lab but also
throughout the state
she serves as the state subject matter
expert in developing testing guidance
for lab testing and is a subject matter
expert for the national cfte covet 19
case definitions work group
our second speaker for today will be dr
wade aldis
dr aldous is currently is the current
senior associate director of the state
hygiene laboratory at the university of
iowa with an adjunct associate
professorship in the university of iowa
college of public health department of
epidemiology
dr aldous is a member of the aphl
infectious disease committee and the
aphl sexually transmitted disease
subcommittee
in iowa he con he contributes to the
preparedness advisory committee the
infectious disease stirring committee
and the healthcare associated infection
advisory group
his research interests are focused on
clinical microbiology
and infection control and multi-drug
resistant organisms
he has authored more than 40 articles
and five book chapters
our last speaker for today will be dr
sarah blasser
dr blosser is currently the molecular
scientific liaison at roche diagnostics
in the division of medical and
scientific affairs where she focuses on
molecular diagnostics and public health
dr blaser is a diplomat of asm's
american board of medical microbiology
previously dr blasa served as the
indiana department of health
laboratories director of clinical
microbiology where she managed the tb
arln ctng mycology and acid development
testing groups
during the kobit 19 pandemic she served
as indiana's indiana laboratory's
testing network program manager
coordinating all of the field testing
for indiana's public health based
initiatives
dr blaser's research interest include
acid validation malditel of mass back
antimicrobial resistance and public
health
i would i would like to now start
today's presentation
dr srikel you may now begin your
presentation
thanks so much for having me today i'm
really excited to be able to share the
perspective of the wisconsin state
laboratory of hygiene and our experience
with molecular testing with sars kobe 2.
in my talk today i'm going to be going
over kind of what we went through in the
early parts of the pandemic with our
molecular testing and some strategies we
used to keep testing and to build our
capacity and stay afloat through the
wave of covid
so
i think many of us were kind of watching
covet as it first emerged in china
wondering if this was going to fizzle
out like sars had or if it was going to
grow and explode and become an arch
outbreak
as we saw cases really starting to
explode and popping up in other parts of
the world we knew that this was real and
from very early on we were working to
see what we could do to prepare in
advance
for testing needs here in wisconsin
well it hit us pretty early we were one
of the first states to get a positive
covet case while someone came down with
symptoms in late january they were
officially
diagnosed as the first case in wisconsin
in february 5th they had recently
traveled to china
we spent a lot of time early on shipping
additional samples from this patient to
the cdc
and we really wanted to start bringing
on our testing as quickly as possible
it's so much easier to just do the test
ourselves get that faster turnaround
time for your patients as well so on
february 7th we received our first test
kit from cdc and we got to work
immediately
by the end of that day on a friday
nonetheless we already knew something
wasn't quite right
with a lot of confirmatory testing by
monday we were very certain that the
verification had failed due to random
false positives seen in the m3 marker we
weren't going to be able to use this
test for patients
we were pretty frustrated the
test that had been approved by the fda
as an emergency use authorization or eua
test
that was produced by the cdc had four
different pcr markers and one two three
and then rnp as an internal control so
that m3 marker was the one that was
giving us a hard time
and it took what felt like forever uh
for the new test to come out
unfortunately at that time fta did not
allow lab developed tests when an eua
was in place there really wasn't much we
could do ourselves we had to wait for
cdc to produce a new test for us to use
it wasn't until february 26 that n3
marker was officially dropped by the cdc
um and by the included with the fda eua
and we were allowed to continue moving
forward once again we very quickly got
through verification
and by the end of the day on friday we
had completely
completed our verification we're ready
for testing for our first in-house test
for sars kobe 2 here in wisconsin
we officially went live on monday
accepting samples and doing patient
testing
and that's when it really started
getting hard
so our testing had very humble
beginnings the tests that we got from
the cdc
really didn't allow for a lot of
flexibility and used a lot of time and
reagents it was basically
from the basic building blocks of doing
uh pcr tests nothing came really well
prepackaged
so our capacity starting out was only 45
people per day which in today's
standards it seems incredibly low
at the time both nasopharyngeal and
oropharyngeal swabs are required on
every patient
and only the easy one extraction
platform or manual extractions are
really approved for this test
so with running a single easy one
instrument we could only run 14 samples
per day and with two samples per patient
that was only six and a half uh patients
per run we could maybe fit in about
seven easy one runs a day per max if we
were really pushing the maximum of our
day for a total about 45 patients
pushing this all through it became even
more complicated because we had to do
three targets per specimen so for each
person tested they had to have six pcr
reactions plus the controls that go
through the extraction controls the pcr
controls also added a lot to this
the first cdc kits came with enough
tests to do a thousand pcr reactions
this equated to about 155 people per kit
and we were only receiving about one kit
per week they were in really really high
demand so if testing at our max capacity
our supplies could last us about 3.7
days that's it that's not very long and
the demand was huge now thinking early
on in normal times we would have offered
this kind of test with a two to five day
turnaround time from receipt in the lab
another key point due to you know if
something a lives rate in the day or a
rise on a weekend then we would
test it the following monday
so
this kind of turnaround time was really
not what people were looking for early
on the pandemic and this kind of
capacity while similar to a lot of our
other tests was simply insufficient
for
the demand that was coming up
so we had to make some really tough
choices
there was a lot of demand to test
everything now a whole bunch of volume
right now and that would lead to of
course happier customers and we would
have
really fast results coming out if we
pushed everything through at once or we
could take a different panel and decide
to test a little bit every day this
leads to less burnout for our staff we
never stop testing if we can get
reagents again before our current ones
run out and then we try to save our
tests for really urgent situations and
that was the strategy we decided to go
with the test a little every day which
wasn't always the most popular decision
there was an immediate massive demand
for testing it started out with
questions even in february calls from
labs hospitals organizations all wanting
to get testing there was an immediate
interest in mass routine asymptomatic
screening and there was a lot of people
calling in favors and asking for special
treatment for their specific uh
population that they wanted to get
testing in which was really very
difficult we had to take the entire
state as a whole and try to make testing
as equitable as possible
well questions turned into demands and
demands turned into outrage we had
people who demanded we moved to 24 7
testing we're normally a nine to five
weekday kind of operation here
they demanded that we
take on way more samples and scale up
and
do more with what we what we had but
really it was very difficult to try to
communicate early on that while we got
these kits from cdc that can do a
thousand tests that doesn't mean we can
test a thousand people and even if we
did all the samples in one day that
means you couldn't test tomorrow so
communicating this with our partners was
a bit of a challenge and some people
went to outreach there was continued
escalation to higher and higher people
within the organizations
threats of irreparably damaged
relationships and long-term consequences
despite all the threats we really had to
stick to our guns and do what we thought
was best for our patients and best for
the state as a whole
and then it happened and we'll always
remember st patrick's day
march 17th in 2020 because that's when
things really got difficult
we had spent many many hours
communicating with our partners to
explain our test limitations that 45
tests per day doesn't mean 45 from one
facility it means 45 from the entire
state and we couldn't tell them how many
they could do and if every one of our
submitters submitted one sample it would
overwhelm us so we try to encourage them
to really prioritize symptomatic
high-risk patients and we did as much
outreach as we could possibly do with
phone calls emails meetings webinars lab
messages out to the whole state anything
we could do to get the message out that
they needed to focus and prioritize
their testing
unfortunately
this did not stop them from sending
samples and on march 17th we had 800
samples arrived in one day this was 17
times greater than our current capacity
for testing at that time now
unfortunately we've been able to get
some more reagents in in that time it
could test
just under 250 people
so this was
really really concerning there was no
way we're going to be able to test all
of these people and the sample volume
had just increased every single day and
everything led to even more samples are
going to be coming tomorrow no matter
how much we ask nicely for them to
prioritize it wasn't necessarily the
case most of the samples we were getting
were an asymptomatic people
so with no way to test everything that
showed up we had to do something and
it's something no reference lab ever
wants to do
we asked a national reference lab to
take some of these samples to us it was
important that whatever patient had been
collected and sent to us in good faith
should get some kind of result but there
was no physical possible way that we're
going to be able to get through all of
these samples of a reasonable amount of
time
so we sent 500 samples to a reference
them
so this next part of my talk i want to
go into the strategies we took to try to
manage at this time it felt like
drinking from a fire hose way more was
coming at us than we were ever going to
be able to manage and we needed to come
up with strategies to make this
more realistic more manageable and for
best possible patient care
so we desperately needed help we worked
with our state department of health and
human services our dhs and they set
testing criteria that allowed us to
prioritize testing for symptomatic
high-risk individuals so i think people
more familiar with this today all the
people out there that could be tested
the vast majority of that is really
routine asymptomatic screening
within those difficult times where we
had shut down there was a lot of
essential personnel that we didn't want
getting sick people with high risk
occupations like nurses paramedics
those in close contact with sick people
plenty of people out there with symptoms
were going through a particularly high
flu season at the time as well
and we really
just prioritized only started accepting
those at the very peak of this triangle
the high risk symptomatic people
um
we worked really hard to help support
other labs bring up their own testing as
well this was something that was really
important that while we could only test
those who needed it the most it doesn't
mean that everyone else doesn't need
testing if there wasn't some value in it
we just physically could not take on all
that testing ourselves and so we worked
with state partners to help
connect with reference labs for them to
support testing needs throughout the
state we supported a lot of other
clinical labs throughout the state as
well building reference panels for their
validations
doing confirmatory testing for the new
assays that they developed we put
together weekly educational webinars and
so much training and communication out
there
to really help them build the state's
capacity for testing and another big win
for us was our collection kit
manufacturer and distribution at one
point during the pandemic it was so hard
to find a collection kit to swab
somebody in the first place for testing
that people were scavenging clinics that
had been shut down these stories of
walking through these dark abandoned
clinics and scavenging through drawers
to try to find some scarce
random collection kit for cova testing
that was really a major limitation so we
started building these collection kits
in-house ourselves and as cases rose
through those first months um within a
week or two we recognized that these
collection kits were going to be in
shortage we started making our own it
still wasn't enough so we partnered with
other reference labs to make these kits
as well um
that diagnostic lab nearby was a huge
help as well another local partner who
was able to source those swabs which
were impossible to get and when we had
the kits we could send them out to
others so that would not only facilitate
them for testing with us but facilitate
testing for the state as a whole
this became quickly unmanageable with
the demand and volume that needed to go
out and so we worked closely with the
state emergency operations center the
seoc to take over kit distribution and
they got their portal up and running
around april 20 20th which was great
timing because then fema started sending
their relief supplies about a month
later and we already had a system in
place that we could get those supplies
from fema and get them out to clinical
labs ouch people doing testing as
quickly as possible to really support
and build capacity for the state as a
whole this was really a strategy that
there was no way our little lab could
take over the entire needs of the state
but building a team and working
state-wide approach to build that
capacity was really our focus that
allowed wisconsin to get the testing it
needed
shout out to our key labs early on that
helped with that
altogether we've now distributed more
than 70 million items and it keeps going
there's still a demand today
so another problem that we dealt with
was managing our reagent shortages now
this was a real problem because
this test was kind of build your own
right it wasn't all pre-packaged like
getting cookie dough so we used the
cookie
reference metaphor to help explain to
our partners what our reagent shortages
really meant uh if you don't have eggs
if you don't have sugar you're not going
to be making a batch of cookies and each
one of those items that were short at
different times and were different
bottlenecks that came up so we did daily
monitoring of our testing supplies to
know how many tests we could run it at
any given time and one of our big
successes was we traded with other labs
uh was something a lab that was using
the same extraction platform as us had
more plastics than liquids and we had
more liquids than plastics and so we
traded on a couple occasions and both of
us were allowed to were able to continue
testing for a little bit longer we also
had donations from researchers at the
university campus and borrowed from
others and really worked to
get supplies from wherever we could when
they were really unavailable and hard to
find
and we diversified our testing that was
one of our biggest strategies to allow
us to keep going when the supplies were
un available for one test type we
switched to a different test type and
had multiple test types running at once
i'll talk about that more in a moment
we did a lot of cross training as well
early on in the pandemic right around
that march april time frame
we saw an
incredible
increase in the amount of our virology
testing really due to sars cov2 testing
that came up
in comparison to our standard volume in
our lab that was really huge
with the lockdown and everything
happening
a lot of our testing dropped off pretty
dramatically in late march april and may
we had very low volumes for other tests
so instead of having one team of our
virologists doing massive amounts of
work everyone sitting around twiddling
their thumbs we cross trained as much as
possible and it was all hands on deck we
developed a coven surge team and this
really helped when one day a huge volume
of tests could come in we could pull
from other teams to get through those
samples to get a reasonable turnaround
time and get through those volumes we
trained people outside of our department
and borrowed space from other parts
because just like we had seen in dip in
our testing other parts within the state
lab outside of communicable diseases
also saw dips in testing and so we
pulled from whatever resource we really
could to expand our testing capacity
i do want to point out here just how big
of a difference that really is in our
sars kobe 2 testing compared to all of
our other testing our public health lab
is really not built for these huge
volumes of testing
this picture shows our virology
laboratory you can see just how small it
really is and when we tried to fit a
whole bunch of people into it to do the
testing it was elbow to elbow and it got
hot and uncomfortable particularly
because they had to wear enhanced ppe uh
we're connected with the university of
wisconsin who has a pretty strict bio
safety program uh that said that if
somebody had handled a leaking specimen
without wearing respiratory protection
they were considered exposed and would
potentially have to quarantine uh for
the you know 14 days during that time
and taking a worker away during this
time peak time was just not something we
could accept so we had all of our staff
wearing enhanced respiratory protection
in case there was a leaker
that they wouldn't have to go into
quarantine we wouldn't lose all of our
staff to that and certainly we don't
want any of them getting sick either
and unfortunately we saw at least one
liquor every day for those who have done
this testing it was it was amazing we
had submitters from places that we'd
never had submitters before
and
every kind of leaking issue from
mis-threaded caps to people who had
shoved the entire swab in a tube and
screwed it on effectively spring loading
the caps for when we opened them we got
a nasty surprise so we had to take some
extra precautions to really stay safe in
the lab when handling these kinds of
specimens
our staff worked long hours and weekends
we had the crowded working space it was
very repetitive work and we ended up
having pretty high turnover about half
the people in this picture alone
are no longer in the lab they've moved
on to other positions and so we've been
hiring new people and training
through all of this as well and doing
what we can to continue to support this
testing
i talked before about diversifying our
testing and this was really a key part
to allowing us to keep testing over time
starting with those manual extractions
and easy one really the capacity just
could not keep up with the demand so as
soon as the restrictions were relaxed a
little bit and cdc started adding other
platforms we really worked with that as
best we could we first moved into
existing extraction platforms we had
in-house the magnapure and emag both
helped to expand our capacity quite a
bit and then we got our first king
picture flex on loan from our vet
diagnostic lab so thank you so much wdl
you were really a wonderful wonderful
help for us uh though we got i think up
to five king fixtures at one time i
expanded further into the kaya cube and
so we had multiple platforms running at
any given time so if we ran out of
reagents for the emag which happened
quite frequently we could work out with
the kingfisher the kayak cube so it was
a diversification everything running at
once all hands on deck and we did
eventually get a couple panthers as well
fortunately we already had an order in
place we were already planning to move
to the panthers these systems are really
nice because it's very hands-off the
extraction and the amplification
detection are all in one instrument you
can walk away after loading it leave it
loaded overnight and will keep running
and report your results out in the
morning so this helped to build our
capacity as well with about 300 samples
per day on a panther
surrounding all of these together we
were able to really
manage the huge volumes that continued
to come in despite having our testing
focused on high-risk symptomatic people
we still got very very high volumes for
our small lab
so in our lab it was diversify or die
overall we've done more than 30
validations verifications and bridging
studies for sars kobe 2. this is
everything from those different
extraction platform testing methods that
we talked about to different test kits
from different suppliers different
specimen types different collection kits
that we had to diversify because they
were so hard to get
including pbs homemade versus commercial
we also did some testing with different
types of storage times and extensions
the the
72 hours at 4 degree original rule for
this test was simply
not possible for some of our more remote
locations they just couldn't get us
samples in time and so we had to do some
extension studies and to find that these
specimens were still acceptable after
longer periods of time
we also worked on sequencing as well
this really became a high priority focus
for us as the capacity for the state
increased and there was more
alternate locations to do coveted
testing we could really focus using our
resources and experience on sequencing
to do the variant surveillance which has
been a really powerful tool so we've
expanded and done additional validations
and testing with
high throughput liquid handlers i have
some here on the top
we moved from a mic to a next seat to
try to expand our additional
sequencing capacity the minion to the
grid ion anything we could do to grow
and expand our sequencing capacity as
we're doing a lot of that for the state
another strategy we took was we got a
lot of questions about data up-to-date
data what's going on right now and a lot
of demand for that our lead
bioinformatician kelsey floric built
this wonderful data dashboard for our
sequencing data so people could go
online in real time see what those
results were and they weren't calling us
all the time to get those results this
has been a really useful tool to get the
information out to those who need it
and take some of the burden off inside
the lab sharing that information as the
questions came in
we also worked closely with dhs to build
a survey so if you're not aware the
wisconsin clinical laboratory network is
one of the big successes in our public
health system the public health lab is
very
closely connected with our clinical labs
here and this allowed us to communicate
information in real time and to collect
information in real time so early on we
built this lab capacity survey real-time
survey people could update as they went
and this helped us to see
what how many labs in the state were
testing or we're planning to test uh
this looked at our total capacity over
time and we could see it increasing so
this told us that
our efforts are working or where we
might need to put more efforts into
building capacity we could see what
instruments that they were using the
gene expert was the most popular uh here
in wisconsin from very early on but was
also one of the hardest reagents to get
and this was a really key part as well
we collected data on what kinds of
shortages there were as well this not
only helped us to
learn about what tests you might want to
do at the public health labs we didn't
compete for supplies with the clinical
laboratories
so we stayed away from the gene expert
there in the end didn't end up using
that for ourselves so that there would
be more tests available for the clinical
labs who needed that really fast
turnaround time and it also helped us to
work to advocate for the state we got
letters written from the governor
connected with manufacturers with the
entire state's information behind saying
that the state of wisconsin needs these
tests and tried to advocate on a higher
level to bring supplies to help everyone
in the state and build up our capacity
so we could see
how many labs had shortages how severe
those shortages are if they were i'm
going if they had
already had the stop testing due to a
shortage or
pending shortage
stopping testing soon too
so all together everything that we did
we tried so many strategies but really a
lot of things that were really key in
helping us to continue testing and to
continue to maintain a reasonable
turnaround time was really
diversification of our test methods
cross-training and building our coveted
search team and supporting other labs to
bring on testing this effort was way
more than any single lab could ever
handle and that communication and
collaboration with others was really key
for this with the outcomes from our
efforts as we maintained a 48 hour
turnaround time through this entire part
of the pandemic except for that that
first 800 samples that was our only time
we weren't there and we never stopped
testing even though we had these supply
shortages we were always testing every
single day and we helped to bring up the
statewide capacity to more than 60 000
tests per day when the survey last
checked and even more now that we've
connected with a lot of national
reference centers as well so really
these external partnerships have
strengthens with wisconsin's response to
pandemic and have been a key part in our
public health response uh so with that
uh hopefully i didn't take up all my
time here i'm gonna pass this on to the
next person thank you so much for
listening
my name is wade aldis i'm one of the
associate directors at the state
hygienic laboratory working at our
facility in iowa city i'm going to
presenting some information regarding
covid serology testing that we've
performed over a two year period
since the pandemic began
a lot has already been discussed about
people's covet experiences so i'm only
going to focus on some of the reasons
why we decided to bring on serology
testing we had discussions with several
groups our state public health
department local providers and the local
blood donor facilities
the iowa department of public health was
interested in testing to support several
iowa businesses
and one of the largest employers in the
state is tyson foods with several food
production plants throughout the state
this was where some of the earliest
outbreaks occurred on the processing
lines so
shl performed a lot of testing for them
during the early stages of the pandemic
over one weekend for example we received
5 000 nasopharyngeal swabs for pcr tests
and 1500 serology samples to perform
testing
local providers were anxious to perform
testing on specific patients and finally
the blood donors facilities were gearing
up to recruit potential convalescent
plasma donors and these are the three
main facilities that we perform testing
for
when we first began we had to put out
some ground rules for testing because we
were afraid that we might get overrun
with specimens
and as you can see here the first two
criteria still hold true today
covid serology testing was never meant
to be diagnostic in nature but rather to
assist with diagnosis by combining these
results with the results of other tests
mainly pcr
the first criteria to help confirm
whether a person truly has been infected
to help determine quarantine status
or or disposition the second criteria to
identify potential convalescent plasma
donors was our main reason to for
performing testing as for the third
criteria at the time there was little to
no knowledge about the pathology of a
code infection
so being able to prove that essential
workers had recovered and developed
antibodies gave providers confidence
that these individuals
could return to work without fear of
infecting naive individuals
we recognized the need to perform
testing in bin march 2020 but at the
time there were no fda
use authorizations for any kits
there were several assays in development
but with undetermined availability
our testing choices would be limited to
the existing instrumentation in our lab
we had an advent architect for testing
for hiv and the viral hepatitis and two
beckmann culture dxi instruments which
we use for maternal screening
the third option would be to run a
manual elisa
now obviously since antibody assays for
sars cov2 didn't exist prior we had
several concerns regarding testing
there were no available reference
materials or a gold standard to compare
the new tests against
and limited knowledge of the virus
pathology regarding length of immunity
there was also concern that there might
be cross-reactivity with circulating
coronaviruses and perhaps issues with
other conditions
namely autoimmune disease
looking at the kid inserts of the assays
that we brought on they all put in a
clause about false positives unless they
all recommended confirmation of positive
results with a second assay
so the only kit that we were actually
able to acquire
were the uroimmune iga and igg assays
the iga was developed as an alternative
for igm testing
iga is associated with secretions and
plays a role in mucosal membrane immune
function
we began testing in early april on our
test validation
and working with our colleagues from the
blood donor centers they provided us
with serum samples for patients who
claimed to have had covid
we quickly determined that unless they
had a known pcr-positive result many of
these individuals had negative
serologies
the donor centers then focused
specifically on recruiting confirmed
positive patients
which resulted in positive igg results
because most of our testing was
performed on serum from recovered
patients we mainly just performed igg
testing
and once an individual had a confirmed
positive result the donor centers kept
them on their recruiting lists so that
they could donate future units
over the next few months we could see a
pattern of a slow downward trend on
those signal to cutoff values
similar to what was
noticed in this early published paper
from finland where they ran multiple
sequential serum samples on the first
noted coveted case in the country
in mid-april the first assays with fda
emergency use authorizations became
available so we began validating other
tests that we could use on our existing
instrumentation
while all clinical facilities were
struggling to find available reagents
and consumables
we realized that we would need to have
redundant testing methods to ensure that
we would be able to continue testing for
our clients
and now a little more than two years
down the road many laboratorians
probably still have some
ptsd from their kova testing experiences
public health labs were not immune to
this either but in retrospect i'd like
to say that there was a little bit of a
silver lining from this overall
experience for us
because the testing began as the testing
began to exponentially increase we got a
lot of support from the federal
government by the way of cdc funds to
help us purchase some new instruments
and testing reagents to meet those
testing demands
my staff had been looking at the dsr and
liaison instrument as a potential
replacement for our aging architect
instrument
so we were able to purchase one
and we also realized that we needed to
establish several high dollar contracts
as a way to ensure that we would always
have testing capabilities
now a little bit of information
regarding covent serology assays there
are three different immunoglobulin
assays igg
igm and iga along with the total igg igm
assay
they detect mainly binding antibodies
but some are known to actually detect
neutralizing antibodies
and there are two main anagenic targets
the nucleocapsid and the spike protein
here you can see the different methods
types of results units and overall
interpretations
one thing that's important to note is
that only those assays that target the
nucleocapsid can distinguish whether an
individual was truly infected
since the available code vaccines are
designed against the spike protein
and these are the different testing
methods that we validated after we had
two validated assays we began to perform
orthogonal testing specifically for the
blood donor specimens
we used either the abbot or the beckmann
culture assays for screening purposes
and if positive we reflex to the uromune
or the deosorin assays
because the euro immune was a manual
assay my staff was very excited to
replace it with the deosorin assays
first the s1s2 iggsa and now currently
with the trimeric s igg assay
so we began testing in april 2020 mostly
to support the blood donor centers to
recruit donors for convalescent units
we reported the signal to cutoff ratios
and interpretations of the assays
to the donor centers to help them
identify those units that could be used
for donations
this information was shared with the fda
which led to the determination of high
tighter concentrations
to improve treatment effectiveness until
monoclonal antibody therapeutics became
more mainstream
in november the wife served blood center
asked if we would perform testing on all
blood donors instead of just confirmed
pcr-positive recovered patients as an
incentive to increase the number of
donors
and as you can see here these graphs
show the monthly average number of tests
performed and the zero prevalence over
time
when life serves stopped active
collections of plasma in march 2021 they
had stockpiled over 20 000 high tider
units for distribution across the state
and for other states in need
we continued to perform testing for them
until the end of december 2021
with roughly 250 000 specimens tested
overall
so one of the benefits of the pandemic
was that it increased the overall number
of potential donors there was a dramatic
increase in the number of first-time
donors
as well as a large number of individuals
that kept returning to donate again and
again
and this map on the right generated by
our colleagues at the life-serve blood
donor center indicates the location of
many of the coveted serology positive
donors
i'd like to close this topic with some
commentary from some of my colleagues
from the clint micronetwist server
they asked the question is there a role
for antibody testing for sars cov2
the answer is yes
we help the blood donor centers identify
thousands of potential donors for
convalescent plasma
and based on current fda guidance
thousands of the specimens
could have been labeled high titer for
treatment
we were also able to look at the data
for seroprevalence studies as i
mentioned earlier
there is a high sero prevalence rate in
the state of iowa
and because we have test values on
multiple repeat donors i currently have
a biostatistics graduate student looking
to determine the duration of immunity
caused by natural infection
vaccination
or hybrid by performing survival
analysis
a final role would be to monitor immune
responses to covet vaccine candidates
which we are not participating in
when this paper was published in august
2020 the idea of performing covid
serology at a population level to guide
return to work decisions or to restart
the economy was a topic of widespread
discussion
but it was felt that things were
inconclusive then
we fast forward now to april 2022
and there's a new question regarding
immunity to sars cov2
what do we know
and should we be testing for it
questions such as am i immune or how
long does immunity last or what is
better vaccine or infection-induced
immunity and why aren't we testing for
immunity these continue to be raised
still
the problem is that all of these
serology assays were meant for
determining infection status and not
immune status
thus there is a push to identify a
correlate of protection to help us
better understand protective immunity
against a specific disease
for sars kovi 2 there is not an
established cop yet because there is a
need to standardize these serology
assays against an international standard
numerous articles indicate that
seropositivity significantly decreases
the risk of infection compared to
seronegativity
protection is estimated to be around six
months but that will most likely be
variant dependent
we also recognize that vaccination and
hybrid immunity meaning those naturally
infected individuals that get vaccinated
have been more enduring high tider level
compared to individuals with natural
immunity only
we've seen this in our own data set
but the question still remains whether
infection induced
vaccine elicited or hybrided immunity
how long does protection for disease or
infection last
well it reminds me of the tootsie pop
commercial i used to see on saturday
mornings
with the wise mr owl telling that kid
how long does it take to get to the
bottom of a titsy roll tootsie pop
we may never know
but we do know that routine testing is
still not recommended
the nuclear capsule target is needed to
distinguish a natural infection from
vaccination
and finally with the current omicron
variants known resistance against many
current monoclonal therapies
it has been suggested that recently
collected high tide or convalescent
plasma may prove useful in reducing the
spread of disease
finally i just want to say thanks to all
of our public health heroes across the
country and thank you for listening in
today
hey i'm sarah blosser and for the first
16 months of the covet 19 pandemic i
served as the indiana lab testing
network program manager bringing
together testing resources and hoosiers
to serve public health needs
outside of the public health lab
today i'm going to tell you that story
first i have to start with a disclaimer
i joined roche diagnostics in may of
2021 where i continue to serve public
health by providing education about
public health priorities and initiatives
as a current roche employee however i
want to stress that the information i
share with you today is based on my
personal previous experience while i
work at the indiana department of health
the opinions expressed in this
presentation therefore don't necessarily
represent the views of roche diagnostics
so today i'm going to talk about
indiana's approach to bringing testing
closer to people through near patient
testing
and these approaches require an immense
cooperation between some really
unconventional partners
but what we learned was
maybe this pandemic has something to
teach us
maybe these partnerships aren't as
unconventional as they once were
because these partnerships allowed us to
identify and address problems in a time
frame that we had never used before
so here are five examples of how this
was done in the state of indiana
the first approach was to make testing
more available for at-risk and
underserved populations
and these were primarily locations such
as federally qualified healthcare
centers rural locations and prisons
and this was early on in the pandemic
where testing was really mostly
available in sites that had access to
large hospitals or reference labs and so
we really needed to make sure that these
at-risk individuals also had access to
testing
and how we did that was by deploying 35
id now point of care pcr instruments and
you can see a picture of those in the
lower right hand corner of my screen
we then distributed testing cuts to
sites weekly based on availability and
usage
one thing i'm going to talk about pretty
consistently is the challenge we faced
on how to facilitate reporting
for sites that weren't always hooked
into the state reporting system
if you'll recall there was a large
number of requirements for
reporting to the state so that we could
track cases
and so really
some creative solutions were developed
for this during the pandemic one of the
first ones that we did was to utilize
redcap for individual patient reporting
and you can see a copy of what that
would look like in the upper right hand
corner of my screen
and this allowed for providers on a
web-based portal to report in the
results of the testing
so as the weekly kit allotments were
shipped to the indiana public health lab
the next rural became distribution
logistics for those 35 sites
so our lab preparedness director worked
really closely with our department of
health logistics team to facilitate
these as deliveries initially and
towards the end of this program our
department of health lab container group
was able to then actually begin to
re-box and reship these in a timely
fashion
so the next approach that we took was to
drastically increase the physical
locations for pcr specimen collection
throughout the state
and our goal was to have specimen
collection available in every county
and this approach included mobilization
of both local health departments and
partnership with a company called optum
serve to rapidly increase the patient
facing component of this test
and if you look at the map in the right
hand side of the screen you can see the
blue icons where we eventually ended up
having our sites
and if you look at the population and
distribution in indiana these mirror it
pretty closely
so then we had to figure out how to get
supplies to each of the locations so
they needed ppe swabs etc in order to
run these
so we partnered with a logistics company
then we had to figure out how to get the
specimen from the collection sites to
testing laboratories and indiana as a
state that does not have an existing
courier system for its department of
health lab
so this was just one of the major
features that was required to
operationalize this approach
once those pieces were figured out
laboratory testing was performed by a
network of laboratories including the
indiana state department of health
laboratory
also included in this network were
several clinical labs and some research
labs who obtained pleia certification
and onboarded covid pcr testing for
specifically for this initiative
so again i'm going to talk about the the
it part of things because another major
consideration when you're scaling
specimen collection to be near your
patients
is figuring out how they're going to
have a test requisition how they're
going to record results and how the
patient's going to receive
a record and have that record sent into
the state for reporting requirements
so we tried several different methods
tried paper we tried red cap and
ultimately we partnered with a software
company called zoetech to develop a
mobile application and web-based portal
this interface allowed for patients to
schedule a testing appointment online
and pre-enter their requisition
paperwork
and you can see an example of that in
the icon with the number one
once on site staff could check the
patient and confirm demographic which
you can see in number two
and then print a specimen label number
three
once the specimen was collected the test
order then flowed into the lab testing
network interface and was assigned to a
destination laboratory where it showed
up in the labs pending queue
and i don't have time to talk about this
today but that involved a lot of really
nifty it solutions that were developed
during this pandemic
so once at the laboratory the specimen
would be tested
the lab would release the result and the
result would flow back to zotek
zotech would then send a text message to
the patient number four on the screen
initially this was the only way for a
patient to receive their result outside
of calling our state call center so you
can imagine how busy that call center
was
so later on in the pandemic a patient
results portal number five was
established and this allowed for the
patients to look up their results and
also the ability for them to print a
physical report if they needed it
so once we had specimen collection for
pcr established
the third approach was really to take
point of care testing or also known as
rapid testing into those same locations
and so if you look at the map the sites
that eventually had this point of care
testing were have the orange pin on them
and the goal of this program was to
distribute binax now rapid antigen tests
to our local health department
collection sites
but that's easier said than done
so here i'm recreating for you my
thought process when i was given this
directive by our chief medical officer
my first thought was oh that's an
awesome idea
my next thought was wait this is a cleo
wave test
that means that these sites have to
operate underneath a clia waiver
and then my third thought was oh
goodness how are we going to implement
this
so for those of you who weren't
intimately involved with this during the
pandemic the issues surrounded mass
distribution and publicity
of those rapid antigen tests during a
time when testing resources were
extremely limited
and some individuals with very high
visibility were endorsing their use in a
myriad of settings including schools in
high-density workplaces
the problem was that the tests had been
approved as a clia wave device which
requires the testing location be
certified to perform that testing it
also requires that they have certain
documentation and training procedures
for staff
they have performance procedures for
testing
and then they have a mechanism for
reporting and they have to record all
that in light of being inspected for
that clio waiver
to top it all off those of us that live
in indiana had heard that this resource
these rapid tests would be soon
available and they were not in the most
patient frame of mind
so what did we do
well our preparedness director who was
quarterbacking the entire covent
response for the state applied for her
own clia waiver she then allowed that
waiver to be used only for binax antigen
testing for a select number of sites and
for a limited duration
first to use this mechanism where the
local health departments and our
department of corrections or prison
system
later in the pandemic this mechanism was
also used to bring up finance testing in
jails schools and in drug and rehab
facilities
but that still left training
documentation and reporting requirements
that were required to deploy a clio wave
antigen test
and so for training our issue is that we
needed to quickly disseminate training
throughout the state
so we needed to develop a centralized
training
we started with a quick start guide with
some basic instructions
watch some videos read the package
insert take a training quiz
perform a positive and negative qc test
and then document your training
and i'm not going to show you all the
pieces here but i can say that some of
the biggest pieces of concern in the
public health community was on this
documentation component so here's two
examples of what we did
one was a certification of binax now
training that each site needed to
maintain on site in case of inspection
and the other one was an acknowledgement
of responsibilities because we needed
sites to understand that this was being
done in a way that required them to have
deep consideration and documentation
uh for the purposes of this testing
program
from there we worked to teach labs to
fish so to speak
by helping them to obtain their own clio
waivers and operate testing
independently at their site
to help this we ended up creating an
application package which included some
background information a preparation
checklist and a guide to help them fill
out the waiver application
armed with these materials we then work
to approach non-traditional sites to
offer clia wave testing at their
facilities
and three areas of focus were homeless
shelters
congregate care homes for individuals
with disabilities and k-12 schools
this continued our approach of teaching
amanda fish or as i often described
during that time teaching folks to make
box mac and cheese
i actually became known as the mac and
cheese lady
we
created videos to demonstrate the
patient interaction as you can see here
in the upper left hand corner
infographics to indicate what supplies
were needed for testing and how that
testing workflow might proceed
we also did in-person train the trainer
sessions
one of my more memorable experiences was
training the indiana national guard
once trained the national guard could be
asked to go to k-12 schools to help
train on-site staff
for the requirements and logistics of
testing their goal was to spend half a
day per site helping the school set up
an optimal testing workflow in their
location
and to help the school staff feel
confident in their ability to perform
testing for their students
you can see here in the bottom left-hand
photo all the way to the left is dr box
our health commissioner
so when i think back on these efforts
those five mechanisms i showed you
i can't help but be proud of the
tremendous superb effort on the part of
all of our partners to rapidly scale
testing for the pandemic response
our teams were asked daily to pull
rabbits out of hats so to speak
to test people for a disease we've never
seen before all while under tremendous
pressure
today i have touched on only some of the
ways that our health department sought
to increase testing availability
throughout the state of indiana
i don't have time to cover the testing
efforts and long-term care facilities
mobile testing clinics high-density
workplace initiatives university
services
or the countless ways the health
department work behind the scenes to
supply ppe food ventilators staffing and
so much more on a daily basis these
folks stood up and they continued to
every day to squeeze one more thing out
of a system that was truly never
designed to handle a pandemic of this
magnitude
and for that i say thank you
so i started my talk by mentioning
unconventional partnerships
the odd couples that made near-patient
testing available in indiana during the
pandemic
now i'll leave you with this
are they truly that odd
or maybe they represent a vision for the
future i'll let you decide
thank you
thank you dr alice dr circle
and dr plaster for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask the question box
that's located in the far left of your
screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for today
so let's get started with our first
question
based on the kovit 19 pandemic
experience
how prepared do you feel your lab is for
the next pandemic
any any of our speakers want to take a
first step on this question
i can give that one a try um i'd say
a little more prepared um still not
perfectly prepared you know at this
scale this volume i feel like we've got
a little bit more of a playbook of what
we would do next time
but every pathogen is a little bit
different how you would handle it and i
think that there's really
almost the whole does not have the
capacity to do massive
full public health testing on the scale
that we saw with covid
really utilizing those strategies and
our partners in the clinical and
reference lab world
is is going to be key in the future i
don't see how public health can ever uh
meet the demand for for this kind of
testing in the future
you know i think i would actually agree
with you there as well the only thing i
would add is basically uh you can never
be too prepared and don't ever get
comfortable
dr glover anything to add to that
i'm going to defer
all right
all right so our next question is what
pros and cons did you have with the
avid id now instrument
i'm gonna let anybody answer that one
even though i spoke with this book on it
uh alana wade any of you want to chime
in
well we we uh we were given 20 of those
instruments to distribute throughout our
state and all i can tell you is
we shipped out a lot of kits to a lot of
people and then we ended up
with some people saying um we're done
now because we want to do something else
and they actually wanted to take wanted
us to take the instrument back so we
said okay fine we'll send it to someone
else who needs it but these were ones
that were actually identified by our uh
our state public health department
of where they wanted to have these
locations to be
but they they uh they were great systems
to use it's just the hard part i think
for us was getting those results back to
the health department to get them
reported
yeah i'll concur on that one so there's
no automatic interfacing so you have to
have a mechanism to put the results into
the into the system one way or another
so we actually used a paper requisition
many times and then they would go and
transcribe it into that red cap system
so
um definitely something to think about
in the future it's great to have point
of care
uh
pcr scene um but at the same time that
that's definitely a need for um for
reporting and for for you know the
patient component of things
elana
oh i think that you've hit on most of
those we certainly had some issues early
on it was great that they were available
early but they were certainly a lot more
complicated than some of our later
versions of point-of-care tests and
we had a lot of concerns about
safety issues associated with them and
proper training i think it took a lot
more oversight to get those up and
running and some of the other test
methods but
overall glad we had those
early all right thank you for that so we
have time for one last question
so if you were to work on a pandemic
handbook at this time what would be the
top three items you would focus on and
because of the you know time limitation
time limitation maybe only one if you
can take a stab on this
um
well i will try and take that if no one
else does
but i think uh everybody has made this
comment uh previously and that is to
make sure that you have enough staff uh
crosstrain to be able to perform
multiple functions
throughout your site the other biggest
important thing for us
especially with this one had to do with
our supply chain and recognizing that we
needed to have
multiple options to be able to respond
to the testing
i think everybody pretty much had to
have at least
plan a b c d all the way to z double a
whatever so that you could at least make
sure you had continuing testing
capability throughout
but that's that was the hard part that
and of course all the documentation that
goes along with that because during all
this process everybody gets inspected by
their regulatory agencies
i'm going to throw in real fast
automation and workflow and i think
that's
something that we really learned a lot
about and still have a lot to learn
i'm probably repeating myself here but
work early and often with your partner
some really strong communication
certainly we can't do this in a bubble
here we have to all work together to
have a full public health response um
another key one i'll never forget is
don't forget about the collection kits
i think everyone always forgets about
those and they sneak up on you
all right thank you everyone for that
so thank you again dr circle dr alice
and dr blosser for your time today and
your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor rush diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
the interesting questions
questions we did not have time to answer
today and those that were submitted
during the on-demand period would be
will be addressed by the speakers by the
contact information you provided at the
time of the registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you by email when it's
available for replay so we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed the live event today
and with that i'd like to close today's
session by thanking all the speakers and
also thanking the audience for joining
today
thank you bye
you